hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we'll be discussing the question
how similar are Metropolitan French and
Quebec French or québécois in other
words how similar is the French spoken
in France to the French spoken in Quebec
French is one of the world's major
languages and it's spoken in dozens of
different countries and everywhere that
it's spoken the standard variety or the
formal variety that's learned at school
and used in the media is essentially the
same as metropolitan French based on the
Parisian variety of French in informal
speech however there is some variation
with local differences in accent and
vocabulary there's one major variety of
French that is particularly distinct
from metropolitan French and that is the
French of Quebec a culturally distinct
french-speaking province in Canada
French speakers from France often say
that they have trouble understanding the
French spoken in Quebec I should point
out that the formal variety of French
used in Quebec is virtually identical to
metropolitan French the differences lie
in the informal varieties of Quebec and
in informal speech there can be a
considerable amount of difference but
why is Quebec French distinct from
metropolitan French the reason lies in
the settlement of New France in the
later isolation of Quebec from France
New France was an area in North America
that was colonized by France before the
creation of Canada and the United States
the first settlers in New France were
not mainly from the Paris area but from
regions like Normandy and Brittany where
regional sister languages of French
language were spoken rather than French
itself but since French settlers were
outnumbered by English settlers the King
of France king louis xiv sent female
settlers mainly from the paris area to
help bolster their numbers through
marriage and childbirth
since these women were mainly from the
paris area they brought with them their
parisian variety of French which
contributed to the decline of the
regional languages and the adoption of
French among the settler population and
of course the interaction between
speakers of different regional languages
encouraged the use of French as a lingua
franca as a result the language that
developed in New France was similar to
the language spoken by the King and the
aristocracy but was also influenced by
the regional languages of the settlers
the French language became adopted
throughout the various regions of France
later after the
French Revolution of the late 18th
century the variety of French that
became the new widespread standard
language was not the French of the king
in the aristocracy but rather the French
of the bourgeois class who led the
revolution prior to the French
Revolution new France had already been
conquered by the British in 1760 and its
elite had returned to France
the British soon decided to allow the
french-speaking population in what is
now Quebec to continue using their
language as a way to prevent them from
joining the American Revolution against
the British which was taking place to
the south Quebec therefore remained
under British rule but was isolated from
France the French language in Quebec
began developing in its own direction
while the French spoken in France
developed in its own direction
vocabulary the vocabulary of Quebec
French differs from that of metropolitan
French in several ways first the two
varieties of French have taken in
loanwords from English during different
time periods the French of Quebec was
infused with English vocabulary during
the period from 1850 to 1960 for example
the word for job in Quebec French
there's injured in metropolitan French
Ave and in Quebec French weird a
metropolitan French visa in Quebec
French there's chim meaning a male
friend or boyfriend and in metropolitan
French that would be in petite Amie or
in Cooper in Quebec French there's fun
in metropolitan French it's a museum fun
also appears in the phrase a Vlad is fun
which is a direct translation of the
English expression to have fun in
metropolitan French it would be sin
musique expressions like this are called
calx or lone translations another
example is Safed sounds this is
translated from English that makes sense
in metropolitan French it would be sad
you songs and the Quebec French people
say give me to mean you're welcome
but in metropolitan French they would
say do the young
Bienvenue means welcome in all varieties
of French but not you're welcome
in response to thank you
note that these are informal québécois
words which are not considered proper
informal Quebec French which mirrors the
standards of metropolitan French since
1960 there have been French language
protection laws in Quebec and the
general distaste towards anglicisms
metropolitan French on the other hand
doesn't have the same protective
attitude and in recent decades has been
more influenced by English so it
contains recent English loanwords that
are not used in Quebec for example in
metropolitan French they say email but
in Quebec French they say oh cool yell
in metropolitan French there's smart
phone in Quebec they say telephone in
Tunisia stop signs in France say stop
this is not really a part of the French
language it's just an internationally
used street sign but in Quebec the signs
say added another aspect of vocabulary
that differs is that there are some
words or expressions in Quebec French
that seem older or more traditional to
speakers of metropolitan French the
québécois word for shoes is a suti in
metropolitan French it's dishwasher the
québécois word for car or shawl in
France it's immaterial in France sha
means tank as in tank of war another
example is the way to say i miss you in
quebec it's sure mom eagle in France
that would sound rather old-fashioned
and the way people would usually say it
is monkey the French of Quebec also
contains numerous slang expressions and
swear words that are taken from the
Catholic religion perhaps the most
famous swear word of Quebec is that
bottom that others include Carles
meaning chalice I see meaning host or
communion bread these words are only
offensive in Quebec and nowhere else in
the francophone world as far as I know
and the French of Quebec has also just
developed some of its own vocabulary and
expressions for example to go shopping
in Quebec French its files magazine as
if Metropolitan French it's fairly coos
failed you shipping
grammar written French and Quebec is
grammatically identical to metropolitan
French but an informal speech you might
hear some differences in grammar too is
after verbs as a yes or no question
marker touch in blonde this means do you
have a girlfriend
in metropolitan French it's 1022 me
notice here that two is being used as a
yes or no question marker and not as a
pronoun
also notice the québécois word for
girlfriend blonde seats pair this means
is it ready in metropolitan french that
would be seaplane sqc plane here notice
that the subject is third person to be
clear to is nothing but a question
marker here it's not the second person
pronoun to it's also used for emphasis
or exclamation c to shut down that's so
shocking sis you should come next in
Quebec French cook is used as the
relative pronoun more often than in
metropolitan French just shush they
leave Cuba boy this means I'm looking
for the book that I need in metropolitan
French this would be Lucia surely
fiducia Busan and in a sentence with an
embedded question in Metropolitan French
you use a relative pronoun but in Quebec
French the interrogative pronoun is used
chef a kiss kisser
this means I do what I want in
metropolitan French jewfish guru next in
Quebec French the explicit subject of a
sentence is often said as a tag with a
pronoun as the subject in the main
clause
for example mall bus metal monk alive
this means my boss makes me so angry
notice how the subject my boss is set
aside at the beginning separate from the
main clause and then the pronoun e which
is a contraction of eel appears in the
main clause in metropolitan French this
would be multiple movie till dawn cooler
in Quebec French song play said Voyager
towards Monde this means his plan is to
travel around the world in metropolitan
French it would be some porgy voyage
this type of tag is also used in
metropolitan French but is much more
common in Quebec French next there are
some differences in imperative forms in
Quebec French zim Euler this means tell
me or tell it to me in metropolitan
French des lieux moi you can see that
the object pronoun la is positioned
differently and now the negative form
des moines Lipper in metropolitan French
numeral deeper you can see that in the
negative the syntax is quite different
in metropolitan French the object
pronoun ma is used instead of the French
emphatic pronoun moi often pronounced
where in Quebec and it comes before the
verb as does the object pronoun la in
Quebec French they come after the verb
as they do in the affirmative accent
probably the biggest difference between
the French of Quebec and metropolitan
France simply lies in accent without
previous exposure to the French spoken
in Quebec French speakers from Europe
typically have trouble understanding it
and this differs depending on the
socio-economic background and the region
of the speaker the consonants are not so
different for the most part but there
are some differences in Quebec French
before the vowels E and E the consonants
to end become Anza gg whereas in
metropolitan French it's pronounced 2d
there are several different Rohtak
sounds used throughout Quebec including
trill sounds as opposed to the uvular
fricative of metropolitan French however
this is also true in France where some
regional accents have trills rather than
fricatives and in Quebec informal speech
and in many areas the uvular fricative
is also used so the situation in Quebec
and France is similar except that in
France the shift towards the uvular
fricative is more advanced vowels one
difference is that nasal vowels are
quite different in Quebec French there's
cat and in metropolitan French there's
cone another difference is that in
Quebec French long vowels and nasal
vowels
come diphthongs in open syllables so in
Quebec French we have fight but in
metropolitan French there's fit in
Quebec French we have pie in
metropolitan French it's damn related to
that Quebec French retains some long
vowels from older French that have
become short in metropolitan French for
example in metropolitan French these two
words sound the same MIT MIT but in
Quebec French they don't
Miette knit these are just a couple of
examples but there are numerous
distinctions like these in vowels some
words also become contracted in Quebec
French for example su meaning on
followed by a definite article gets
contracted soon sir
see
now let's look at a few sentences to
compare here's a sentence meaning I fell
in love with her because she's beautiful
in Quebec French she told me on I'm all
have a girl I call scary Bell and in
metropolitan French ashita miru heard in
Pascal e-bill here we can see a
québécois expression tombe on a move
avec which is a calque of the English
expression fall in love with and here we
see two different phrases meaning
because a kolka is an older phrase which
is obsolete in metropolitan French but
is still used in Quebec another pair of
sentences this time they mean I want to
go out with my friends on the weekend in
Quebec French for salsa hanggang often
salmon and in metropolitan French
shiva-shakti avec mes amis a weekend in
the Quebec French sentence we see on
gang which means with a group of friends
or colleagues this phrase is strictly a
québécois phrase so in metropolitan
French you'd say something like a Vic
Meza me next we see the phrase offenders
a man which means on the weekend in
metropolitan French the usual term is
the weekend or in this context so
weekend this is an Anglicism that has
not entered Quebec French due to its
language protection efforts in
metropolitan French someone might say
send us a map but to refer to the end of
the work week like Thursday Friday
before the weekend now let's look at one
last pair of sentences this time they
mean I'm going to park the car here and
ride my bike in Quebec French ripoff
kilala see Imhotep stooped and in
metropolitan French Juve gamut of
witchery see upon movie Lu here we see a
uniquely québécois phrase Park inertia
with the verb parque that comes from the
english word park and again we see the
word siya meaning car and notice that
the words for bicycle are different in
Quebec the common word is bicyclette
this word isn't a loanword from english
in fact it appeared in French before the
word bicycle appeared in English it's a
standard French word but is generally
considered old-fashioned to speakers of
metropolitan French who mainly used the
word Velo
as we've seen the French of Quebec has a
number of different features that
distinguish it from metropolitan French
but it seems to me that people sometimes
exaggerate these differences there are
significant differences in accent but
that seems like something that would
cease to be much of a problem with
significant exposure to it in terms of
vocabulary Quebec has its own informal
expressions and slang but so do other
french-speaking areas including Paris in
terms of grammar there are some little
things here and there but nothing too
shocking
and of course formal French in Quebec is
very close to formal French in France
albeit with a different accent the
question of the day for native speakers
of French from Quebec from your point of
view how different is your variety of
French from the French spoken in Europe
and for native speakers of French from
Europe how well can you understand the
French spoken in Quebec and for learners
of French assuming that you're learning
metropolitan French what do you think of
the French spoken in Quebec is it hard
to make sense of be sure to follow Lange
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and once again thank you to all of my
patreon supporters especially my top
tier patreon supporters these wonderful
people right here on the screen many
thanks to them and to everyone thank you
for watching and have a nice day